continuing our look at the very
competitive three races for Clark County
Commission today we're focusing on
District G Billy Mitchell running as a
republican for that seat Jim Gibson's
seat now the incumbent uh Mr Mitchell
good to meet you sir good to meet you
too uh so let's talk about it you were
talking before we started that you've
never run for political office before uh
what motivated you to run and for the
viewers at home for the voters at home
uh some of your background
so um I'm a veteran I was the ex-school
teacher I raced NASCAR I built the
fountains Bellagio a lot of different
engineering projects I'm an engineering
project manager
um I just got to a point where I just
couldn't sit back anymore you know I
defended two Wars and this isn't the
country I remember growing up so I felt
like I needed to get involved and at the
county level seems to be the appropriate
place so what is it at the county level
that you would want to address first
we need to do it all
we need to go through and be more
accountable for the money that's being
spent and what projects I'm working for
DOD now I'm very familiar with
government processes and from what I've
seen at the County Commission meetings
they're not being followed
explain a little bit about that what
what do you mean specifically that's not
being followed give me an example of
something that stands out to you that
you would like to deal with right away
so the
firm to me was I was at the water
commissioning meeting a couple weeks ago
and they just gave him 7.1 million
dollars right off the cuff
the way I'm used to dealing with the
Department of Defense is you have to put
out rfps you have to do a bidding
process and you have to justify that
financing before you can just say
spend 7.1 million dollars on you know
digitizing records or whatever the
excuse here we're giving them so you
you're uh you think that sort of there's
a blank check at the County Commission
that you want to try and deal with oh
definitely I've seen it uh the three
meetings I've been at even with the
voting machines uh Gloria stood up there
and asked for you know another three
hundred thousand dollars and said he
needed it today in order to upgrade
their machines and they did it they it
turned right to the clerk and said he'd
get it to him today you don't you don't
believe they're uh their their issues
and their what they're bringing to the
County Commission is in good faith well
I don't think anybody even looks at it I
think they just could bring it up but
you got seven Democrats that are on
there if you look at some of their
policies during the covid mandates and
everything I don't agree with it I don't
think they were in good faith I think
they are doing what they're told from
the governor and they just fall in line
with their party
we're going to touch on on covet again
in just a second here but let's talk
about some of the other issues specific
to District G although I guess this is
an issue for all of us it's it's the
issue of water
um what do you think needs to be done
from a Clark County commission level to
help with our water shortages our water
issues and what's happening out at Lake
Mead so I think the federal government
needs to get involved and I think that
our County Commissioners and our County
needs to facilitate that that pact that
they have or agreement was from 1920s
they got to a two-way level just a few
weeks ago when the County Commission was
up there the reality is that you know
based off the information that the
Southern Nevada Water Authority
presented to the county that we're not
using any more water now than we did 10
years ago so why is the lake going dry
well it's real simple California is
using way over their allotment when they
got to a 2A which is a tier one level
they were all supposed to come to the
together and come back with cutbacks we
did that a matter of fact I call them
the Gibson mandates now with the pools
and the front yards that they just put
in
um California didn't even come to the
table so at that point what the county
should have done and what the state
should have done is they should have
filed a federal lawsuit against
California for breach of contract and at
that point it would have forced them to
come to the table before it gets down to
a 2B level which the Southern Nevada
Water Authority said is going to be in
less than 24 months and they may have to
shut the dam down do you support some of
those measures acknowledging the issues
with the federal other states and that's
that's a whole other tier but just
specifically the Clark County you
mentioned the Gibson mandates
referencing Jim Gibson do you support
those measures that were implemented by
the county whether it's the the pools uh
the moving removing of Lawns uh do you
support those well I think the big
picture here and now the studies are
coming out that you know as we remove
the Lawns and put in the turf I know
from coach and football that Turf gets
very hot it gets to a point you know it
looks great on the surface but until you
got to play on it I mean the surface
temperature at the high schools with the
turf is well over you know 150 degrees
you got to play with you know long
sleeves so it's going to increase the
temperatures here in Clark County so
what effect will it have on the water
I don't think it's going to have but
maybe .01 of the water usage I think our
Monica and our time to enforce all that
can be used in other ways to like
Boulder City needs a new water treatment
plant which is in my district we could
be using that budget to do that and try
and reclaim water more effectively than
we're doing than to come out to the
constituencies and say okay well we're
going to start regulating you more with
bigger government
you mentioned this a few seconds ago
you're talking about the covid mandates
um how would you have handled
coronavirus whether it's from a a
mandate standpoint with masks or with an
economic aspect with funding and so
forth if you were in the Clark County
Commission two years ago in the depths
of the pandemic what would you have done
so I I looked at it you know serving in
the military and overcome this is
biological warfare okay and they used it
to instill fear this is right out of
Marxism and Machiavelli 101 template
okay you put fear in people fear the
unknown and you can actually get them to
do whatever you want if we compare our
state to other states that did not do
all the things that we did
they're doing better economically did it
affect or curve anything no the reports
came from CDC and from John Hopkins
University that the only thing they
actually did was killed 40 percent of
small businesses and they actually
killed our schools 20 percent of our
kids have not come back to school and 40
percent of small businesses which is the
middle class are gone they're gone they
have never reopened and that's another
issue that we need to facilitate to try
and get those small businesses back
there's 23 steps right now it's way too
expensive you look from anything from an
Uber driver to Mom and Pop shops it's
just accounting can be doing more to try
and facilitate that growth so what more
can be done moving forward if the past
can't be changed what would you do if
you're elected to sort of bring back
that help for small business so we need
to streamline that we need to streamline
the processes as far as getting your
small business the other thing is a
taxation we we're in a recession they
don't want to admit it they're
gaslighting everybody but we're in a
recession so we need to look at it from
a county level and take a look at what
the fees we're charging stop spending
all the money and say okay what can we
do to bring our economy back that's our
number one priority second priority is
obviously law enforcement okay violent
crime is going through the roof right
now I've every time I turn on your news
every morning they're talking about
somebody got stabbed or somebody got
killed I I don't even recognize Las
Vegas that I grew up here this is my
home
um what do you think District G needs
that the incumbent is not providing so
he
even represent District G I've had the
police department the fire departments
all come to me the people and and
Boulder City
um he's a career politician when he left
Henderson he left him with a 90 Min
million dollar deficit that left
everybody with the bad taste in their
mouth when he first got appointed
to county commissioner
he shouldn't have he wasn't elected he
shouldn't he lost the mayor race he
didn't even get through the primary with
Dina Titus he should have just said
that's the end of politics but he didn't
he decided to throw his hat in the ring
at County Commissioner and I don't think
he's really represented Henderson or or
um Boulder City well at all and how
would you as someone who's never been in
politics represented better so I think
we need to look at again small
businesses we need to support our law
enforcement our detention facilities we
need to look at it and say okay what do
these people need to do their job what
do these people need to actually get
their businesses back up and running
water Street District Boulder City
these these small mom and pop shops need
all the help they can get right now and
whether that's just easing the fees
reducing taxes or streamlining the
licensing process through the county it
needs to be done one of the things that
should have been is is not a county
issue it is a county issue but it's not
kind of commission issue is the school
district we've asked candidates high and
low both all political parties about
what can be done break it up keep it
together what changes need to be done
what do you think you would like what
would you like to see done on a County
commission level to try and improve
things with CCSD well the first step is
counting commission means to get
involved okay the County Commission has
no authority over the Clark County
School District which when I first found
that out kind of blew my mind because
they have authority over everything else
including Metro and everything else so
what do we do I'm I'm an ex-teacher I
taught and coached football Coronado
High School in Henderson I saw firsthand
what what the principals and the
teachers are going through they're not
getting the support they need and now
with this new culture that's going
around cancel culture whatever you want
to call it they're just not getting the
backup that they need to do their job
and then we need to look at the
standards because we really need to
change change the standards because the
federal money right now is dictating the
standards and it's it's not doing well
for our students where are our students
at four or five years from now they're
not graduating from college they don't
have a trade school which we need to
really facilitate I'm a big CTE fan
obviously so we need to maybe look at
these process see what we can do to
actually improve our community and
prepare our youth for the future
well good luck in the election District
G's looks like a very interesting race
obviously the incumbent Jim Gibson and
Billy Mitchell who's running right now
for Clark County Commission Billy thank
you thank you